[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - DRAKE, "ICE MELTS"]
[CLOCK TICKING]
[FEET PATTERING]
[WHISTLE]
[NON-ENGLISH WHISPERING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[CLATTERING]
[CARTOON CHARACTERS WHOOPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CROWD CHEERING]
JASON TITUS: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jason, and I run our
developer product group
here at Google, and it is so
great to be back at Shoreline
again this year.
And for those of you joining
via our 400 I/O Extended
sessions across 85
countries, as well as
you joining over the live
stream, thank you and welcome.
Earlier, Sundar talked about our
various billion-user platforms,
and whether it's Android
or the web through Chrome,
our success here would not
be possible without you.
So we're going to spend the
next half an hour diving
deep into exactly what
we're doing for all of you,
the developers who build
on our platforms every day.
[CHEERS]
And no matter what platform
you're building on,
our goal is to make
your job easier,
to allow you to focus
on the problems you're
trying to solve, by
minimizing the pain
points of building a product.
We want to simplify
repetitive tasks,
whether that means
dealing with user log
in or instrumenting analytics
or synchronizing real-time data.
We want to give you the
tools to make it easy
for you to solve everyday
problems in simple and powerful
ways, as well as create entirely
new products using technologies
like machine learning and VR
and voice-enabled interactions.
It is important to us
that you are successful.
So in addition to
building products that
help you build your
apps, we are also
on the ground in
over 130 countries
with programs like
Women Techmakers,
and the Google Developer Groups.
[CHEERS]
Many of whom are here today.
[CROWD CHANTING EXCITEDLY]
[LAUGHTER]
So I believe we have GDGs
from 79 countries here today.
So that's pretty exciting.
[CHEERING]
So we're also investing
in training programs,
like Google developer
certifications and courses
through Udacity
and other partners,
to help you deepen your
technological capabilities.
And from this work
around the world,
we're seeing firsthand
that developers
are at the forefront
of technological change
and innovation.
We see you solving
challenging problems in ways
that could not be done before.
For example, last year
on a trip to Indonesia,
I met Gibran Huzaifah.
Having watched
aquaculture become
an increasingly important
part of his country's economy,
he left a career in biology
to become one of the nation's
3.5 billion fish farmers.
What he found was a
400-year-old trade
that was mired in
inefficiency, where
farmers were frequently over
or under-feeding their fish.
With his co-founder, Muhammad,
they decided they could help,
and they started
eFishery which builds
a smart, automated
fish-feeder that
can sense when fish are
hungry and feed them.
As a result, they
can save the farmers
up to 20% of their
annual cost, as well
as reducing harmful
environmental runoff.
And this is just
one of many stories
of how our global developer
community is making
an impact in unexpected ways.
Now, I'd like to bring up some
colleagues to give updates
across our developer platforms.
Let's get started
with what we're
doing to make Android
development easier.
Please welcome Steph.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE SAAD CUTHBERTSON:
As Sundar and Dave
said, with two billion
active devices on Android
and 82 billion apps
installed from Play,
Android's momentum is amazing.
What I like even more is how
Android's momentum is making
so many developers successful.
The number of developers
with over a million installs
grew 35% just in the past year.
And we're making it easier
to grow revenue, too.
In addition to credit cards,
gift cards, everything else,
we've expanded direct
carrier billing
to reach 900 million devices
with over 140 operators.
Altogether, the number
of people buying on Play
grew by almost 30%
in the past year.
Now, to support
this vast ecosystem
we're working hard to
help developers build
great apps at every stage--
writing your app, tuning,
and growing your business.
Today, we'll walk
through four big themes.
The first is languages.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Next is making Android
development faster and easier
with the IDE and Libraries.
Third, we'll show you even
more tools for building
high-quality experiences.
Finally, we want to help you
grow and reach new users,
leveraging Android Instant Apps.
So let's go straight in.
We have been so excited to
announce first-class support
for Kotlin.
[APPLAUSE]
This starts now.
In Android Studio, Kotlin
support is now built-in.
We'll support building
apps with as much Kotlin
as you want, from
zero to 100 percent.
Now, all of you who've
written code in Kotlin
know why we did this already.
But for everyone, we
did it because Kotlin
is a beautiful
programming language.
We asked one Googler how
he felt after writing
Kotlin for a couple of weeks.
While I would never
embarrass Adam Powell
by using his name on stage, he
said, "I think I am in love."
[LAUGHTER]
So, many of you told me Kotlin
makes programming fun again,
with so many wonderful features
like you're going to see here.
And Tor will show you
more in just a moment.
As developers,
languages are the tools
we use to express our thoughts.
With Kotlin, there's just
so much less syntactic noise
that stands between what I
want to say and how I say it.
Now, for those of you who are
wondering what this may mean
for the Java programming
language and C++,
our commitment
there is unchanged.
We're adding Kotlin and
enhancing our existing
languages.
For instance, in Android
Studio, Java 8 features
are now directly supported
with the Java C compiler
and we've added more Java
8 Language APIs in O.
So if you wish, you can
ignore Kotlin completely
and your existing
language support
will keep getting better.
But if you can't wait to
get started with Kotlin,
it is incredibly easy.
Kotlin works 100% with the
Java programming language,
which means it is
completely interoperable.
That means you can
keep every line of code
in your existing project.
You can seamlessly
call from Kotlin
into the Java programming
language and back, which means
it is very easy to get started.
You can add as little as
a single Kotlin class.
Another reason why Kotlin is
such an amazing fit for Android
is it's mature and
production-ready.
Kotlin has been
around for five years
and major apps like Flipboard,
Pinterest, Square Cash,
Expedia, and more are all
using Kotlin in production.
Now, Kotlin's not
just a great language.
It has outstanding IDE support.
The team that brought you
Kotlin is the same team
behind IntelliJ
which, as you know,
is what powers Android
Studio, our IDE.
Finally, Android has
committed to Kotlin
as a first-class language,
and, as you heard,
we're announcing our plans
to partner with JetBrains
to move Kotlin into a
nonprofit foundation.
Kotlin is already open-source
under Apache 2, which means it
is open and will remain open.
We love how Kotlin fits with
our ethos around community.
And now, Tor would love to
show you Kotlin in action.
So, Tor.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
TOR NORBYE: Thanks, Steph.
So here's a pretty typical data
class with three properties
implemented in Java.
As you can see, there is
a lot of boilerplate code
here with fields,
scatters, setters, equals,
hashCode, and so on.
Let's take a look at how we
would implement this in Kotlin.
So I'm going to go ahead
and delete this class,
and now I'm going to write
the equivalent Kotlin code.
So here's the first line, and
that is also the last line.
That is all you have to write.
This code--
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
This code is completely
equivalent to the 87 lines
I just deleted.
The compiler does all the work.
It generates the
same code as before,
plus some extra goodies.
So from Java, I can call
into my new Kotlin class
and access the same
getters as before.
But look what happens in Kotlin.
Here we have a really
nice property syntax.
So I can, for example,
use assignment
to assign to this property
instead of calling a setter.
Now, as you're starting
out with Kotlin,
you might find yourself
stuck, realizing you
don't know how to do something.
So let's say that I'm about
to do some image processing
and I realize that I
don't know how to declare
a two-dimensional array.
Well, what I can do is
open up a Java file,
write the code in Java,
which I know how to do,
go back to Kotlin, and look
what happens when I paste.
That's right.
The IDE converts it for me.
[APPLAUSE]
That is a huge help when
you're starting out.
So as Steph can attest, I could
literally stand for three hours
and tell you all the
things I love about Kotlin.
And I think I have.
STEPHANIE SAAD CUTHBERTSON: Yes.
TOR NORBYE: But we don't
have time for that.
So instead, I will
encourage you all
to come to our excellent
talks on Friday, where
you'll learn everything
you need to know
to get started with Kotlin.
And I hope you'll love coding
in Kotlin as much as I do.
STEPHANIE SAAD
CUTHBERTSON: Thanks, Tor.
TOR NORBYE: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHANIE SAAD CUTHBERTSON:
For us at Android,
adding Kotlin feels like
a moment in history.
We are excited today.
It's just the beginning, though.
We're even more excited
about the possibilities
that Kotlin creates
for the future.
But there's more.
Our second theme is making
development faster and easier
with our tools and libraries.
Android studios
are official IDE.
It is purpose-built
for Android, and we
keep increasing investment.
Today, we're releasing Android
Studio 3.0's first Canary,
focusing on speed and smarts,
and Android platform support,
plus new libraries
for app architecture.
So let's go straight to a demo.
It's more fun.
All right.
So here I have
Android Studio 3.0,
and I've just built
and deployed my app.
And what you'll see
are the new profilers--
CPU, memory, and network.
So I'm just going
to open the app.
And let me do a
little bit of network
here so you can see
it on the graph.
What you can see is
the network profiler,
and it's really cool that you
can see all of the requests,
but particularly cool would
be if you could click and see
the actual payload
of the request.
Even better than that would
be if you could look and see
the headers, but
I actually think
it would be very cool if you
could click on the call stack
and select and go
to the line of code.
[APPLAUSE]
So those are the
three new profilers.
3.0 also includes
a preview feature
for debugging any APK, so
you can build in any IDE
and debug in Android
Studio, including using
these profilers for Java code.
So to say more on
speed and smarts,
your feedback has
made driving down sync
and build time our
number one priority.
Benchmarking with a real life,
100 module project since 2.2,
the build config
time has dropped
from three seconds down--
sorry-- from three minutes
down to two seconds.
And we will keep
working on build speed.
On the emulators, we've added
Play Store for Android testing.
And there's so much more here.
The next thing I
want to talk about
is Android platform support.
You will find awesome
features for Android and O,
like end-to-end instant app
support, O system images,
and tons of helper tools.
For instance, Dave talked about
adaptive icons, which we all
need to build now,
so our team has built
tools that make that easy.
And one of my personal
favorite features
is, to download Android
dependencies for build,
you don't have to go through
the Android SDK manager anymore.
We're now distributing through
our own Maven repository.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Finally, you have asked us to
make Android Frameworks easier,
like providing an
opinionated guide
to best practices or a better
way of dealing with lifecycles.
We're launching a preview of
new Architecture Components,
libraries for common tasks.
This starts with libraries
for the ViewModel pattern,
Data Storage, and managing
activity and fragment
lifecycles.
We would love if you'd download
and try all of this today.
Now, as we move from coding over
into how to tune your quality
and grow, I'd like you to
hear from Ellie Powers.
Please welcome Ellie.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: Thank you, Steph.
As all of you know, building
a successful business on Play
starts with a high-quality app.
And you've told us
that sometimes you
need to target the right devices
in order to ensure the best
user experience.
So we're making it easier to
understand Android's devices
and target them in
the Play console.
Now, you can browse a
detailed device catalog.
No more searching for
specs one device at a time.
If you need a
certain amount of RAM
or you have a problem with
a specific system on a chip,
you can now set targeting
rules to address that.
Before excluding
devices, you can even
see your installs, rating,
and revenue per device.
Now, ensuring quality
experiences really matters.
The Play team took
a sample of apps
and analyzed the correlation
between app quality
and business success.
When apps moved from
average to good quality,
we saw an amazing
six-fold increase
in spend and a seven-fold
increase in retention.
That is phenomenal.
We are always
looking for new ways
to bring users to your
apps, and Instant Apps
is our big bet in this area.
Last year, we previewed
Android Instant Apps.
Instant Apps allows you
to experience everything
you love about apps, but without
the hurdle of installation.
Since then, we've been
working with partners
to refine the product.
They have launched
50 Instant Apps,
from immersive video with Vimeo
to mobile commerce with Jet
to apartment hunting
with HotPads.
And while it's still
early days, developers
are reporting positive results.
For example, Jet,
HotPads, and Vimeo
are seeing double-digit
increases in purchases,
leads generated,
and videos watched.
So today, we are opening
up Android Instant Apps
to all Android developers.
This means anyone--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
This means anyone can now build
and publish an instant app.
Feedback from our partners has
shaped the development tools
that we're making available to
all Android developers today.
Let's take a look.
You build Instant Apps
in Android Studio 3.0.
Many of you wondered if
building an instant app
means maintaining two
forks of your code, right?
The answer is no.
You can use exactly
the same code
for your instant app and
your installable app.
Your instant app is downloaded
as needed, feature by feature.
So you'll organize your
project into feature modules
and then use that code
in both your instant app
and your installable app.
Now we know refactoring
your app into features
can sometimes be
a bit of a pain,
so we're providing tools
to ease the process.
For example, the new
modularized refactoring action
helps you move code and
resources between modules.
Every app is
different, but we've
seen, with our early partners,
that instant app development
typically takes about four
to six weeks with the latest
tools.
As you all know, the
faster your product
is, the more usage you'll get,
so you'll want each module
to load as quickly as possible.
We're providing
optimization tools,
from space-saving
shared libraries,
to more efficient
asset delivery,
to on-the-wire compression.
And when you're ready, you'll
just upload your instant app
APKs, together with your
installable APK in the Play
console.
If you're getting ready
to build for Android O,
we're introducing new APIs and
behaviors for Instant Apps.
There's a new, more-efficient
runtime sandbox
and users will be able to
find Instant Apps directly
in the launcher and then add
them to their home screens.
Let's look at an example.
I heard about "The New York
Times" crossword app recently.
And I can search for
it in the launcher
and then open it
with a single tap.
I can even drag it
to the home screen
so it's easy to come back later.
By the way, in early
testing "The Times"
is seeing significantly
more engagement from people
playing and completing puzzles.
To get started building
an instant app today,
go to g.co/InstantApps and come
visit us at our I/O sessions
or at the Android sandbox.
With Android in so
many places it's
enabled us to create new
types of experiences,
like the Google Assistant,
bringing Google's intelligence
to billions of people.
It's been really cool to see the
Assistant really coming to life
and rolling out on so
many devices this year.
Next up, we'll learn what the
Google Assistant means to you,
as a developer,
from Brad Abrams.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD ABRAMS: Thanks, Ellie.
In December last year, we
launched an early version
of the Actions on Google
developer platform.
This version lets you
build apps for Google Home.
But since then,
we've been focused
on growing your audience,
expanding the platform feature
set, and improving the
developer experience.
As you heard in the
keynote this morning,
your apps are now available
to Google Assistant users
across Android and the iPhone.
And as we continue to
expand the Assistant's reach
to more surfaces, the
developer platform will follow.
With apps for the Assistant
now available on the phone,
you'll have the opportunity
to grow your user base.
But more importantly,
you'll be able to build apps
for entirely new assistive use
cases, things that previously
weren't well-suited to
a voice-only interface,
such as shopping for
clothes or ordering food
from a lengthy menu.
In addition, with
our new UI elements
such as image carousels,
lists, and suggestion chips,
users can easily get
things done with your app.
They can seamlessly
transition between voice,
typing, and taps, all in
the same conversation.
You can build and deploy apps
for the Assistant on the phone
starting today.
[WHOOPING]
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
We also want to make it
easy to complete purchases
through the Assistant to
help you grow your business.
We designed a transaction
experience on the Assistant
to be easy and lightweight for
users and developers alike.
You heard about Transactions
this morning from Valerie,
but let me expand a little bit
from a developer point of view.
For payments, you
can choose to use
Google-facilitated payments,
which are easy to integrate,
allow you to leverage
hundreds of millions of cards
that users have already
stored with Google,
and are available to
developers for free.
Or you can choose to use a
payment method that users
have already provided you.
To do so, we recommend using
our new, seamless Account
Linking support.
That allows users to sign
in to an existing account
or even create a new
account in just two tabs.
However, the transaction
isn't over when a user pays.
Users may want to check
on the status of an order,
modify an order, or
even re-order an item.
That's why the
assistant now allows
users to see all
their transactions
in a single history view.
Finally, we built a new
orders update feature
to make it easy for users
to reengage with your app.
You're now able to send status
updates to users asynchronously
like, for example, when a
car arrives to pick them up,
when their food is delivered,
or when a prescription is ready.
You can start building and
testing transactional apps
today, and they'll be
available to Google Assistant
users on the phone soon.
But what good are these
transactional features
if users can't
discover your app?
Today, we're rolling
out a new app directory.
Users can access it with a
single tap from the Google
Assistant.
It not only has categories
and user ratings,
it also allows users to try your
app right from the directory
page.
Users can also create a shortcut
to your app for an easy way
to invoke it.
For example, instead
of saying, "OK, Google,
ask forecaster Joe, what's
the surf report for the Outer
Banks," you can just
say your shortcut.
"OK, Google, is the surf up?"
Each apps directory page is
also shareable on the web
so that you can promote
your app to new users,
and your existing users can
share it with their friends.
And to make finding
your app easier,
the Assistant is also
learning from the directory
and other information
provided by the developer.
Thanks to these
additional signals,
the Assistant can
often present users
with a few different options
for general requests like,
play a game.
While we are confident
these features will
help improve discoverability
of your apps,
our work is not done.
Improving discoverability
is important to all of us,
and you can expect ongoing
investments and improvements
in this area.
We're equally invested in
providing a great developer
experience.
Today, we're launching
a new developer console.
The Actions Console helps
you work better as a team,
collect data about
your app's usage,
performance, and
discovery patterns.
This new console is well
integrated with Firebase
and the Google Cloud
console so you can easily
share data with your apps.
In addition to the
brand new console,
we're also providing you
access to developer tools
that let you quickly and easily
build apps for the Assistant.
Since launching
our platform, we've
worked with an expanding number
of developer tools companies
to make their solutions
compatible with actions
on Google.
We're also expanding
the capabilities
of api.ai, our own
conversation-building tool,
launching new features
such as follow-up
intents, pre-built agents,
and in-dialogue analytics.
While we're still at the
early days of the Actions
on Google Platform, we're
focused on making it robust
and expanding its
reach and capabilities.
We're soon launching the
platform in UK English,
with French and German and
other languages following
later this year.
We also intend to bring the
platform to many new devices,
including all those powered
by the Google Assistant SDK.
We're excited about the road
ahead and we want more of you
to join us by developing
for the platform.
With an addressable audience
of 100 million devices,
new capabilities
like transactions
and improved
developer experience,
we think this is an incredible
opportunity for all of us.
You know, the magic
of the Assistant
is enabled by Google's
deep investments
in AI and the cloud.
And to tell you more about
how you can use that directly,
please welcome Fei Fei.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
FEI FEI LI: Hi.
I'm Fei Fei Li.
I'm chief scientist
of AI and machine
learning at Google Cloud.
What an exciting day.
I've been doing AI research
for almost two decades,
and I can honestly say
these last few years have
been the most exciting
of my entire career.
AI is transforming
everything Google does.
And as we speak, industries
from finance to health care
are augmenting
human capabilities
with machine insights.
But building AI expertise
is a significant investment,
and we know that
many of you simply
haven't had the opportunity.
I joined Google precisely
for this reason,
to ensure that
everyone can leverage
AI to stay competitive and solve
the problems that matter most
to them.
In other words, we're
meeting you where you are.
We call this democratizing AI.
And I'd like to share a
few examples in action.
First, we're democratizing
the algorithms
that make AI so powerful
with a collection
of high-level
machine learning APIs
that can help your
applications understand
the content of images, videos,
audios, and natural language
with minimal efforts.
Whatever your
level of expertise,
these are tools you can put
to use immediately and see
results.
At the same time, we're
equally focused on developers
ready to build their own models.
In November 2015, Google
open-sourced TensorFlow,
a software framework
for machine learning
that is used extensively
throughout Google.
Today, we're continuing
the evolution
by bringing you high-level
APIs in TensorFlow 1.2.
That makes it easier for you to
start training machine learning
models on your data
right away using the best
hardware you have available.
I encourage you to check
out our TensorFlow sessions
to learn more.
Additionally, we also
launched the Cloud machine
learning engine to help you
manage large-scale TensorFlow
training and prediction
jobs in the Cloud.
Of course, there's no
getting around the fact
that AI requires enormous
computational resources.
And this represents one
of the steepest barriers
to entry for developers.
To address this, Sundar
announced this morning
that Google has developed
a second-generation TPU,
or Tensor Processing Unit,
that can train machine learning
models, as well as run them.
Our TPUs deliver a
staggering 180 teraflops
and are built for just the
kind of number-crunching that
drives machine learning today.
To put this in perspective,
our new large-scale translation
model takes a full day to
train on 32 of the world's best
commercially-available GPUs.
While only one
eighth of a TPU pod
can do this just
in an afternoon.
But TPU specs are only
part of the story.
The real breakthrough
lies in how
we're working to democratize
computation as a whole.
Google Cloud Platform
allows us to make
this incredible new hardware
available to everyone.
You'll soon be able
to rent Cloud TPUs
without any up-front capital
expenses, the same way you can
rent other infrastructures
on Google Compute Engine,
paying only for what you need.
We strive to ensure consistent
experiences and painless
interoperability,
whether you're running
your cloud on CPUs, GPUs,
TPUs, or whatever comes next.
If you're interested in being
one of the first developers
to train machine learning
models on Cloud TPUs,
please sign up at this link to
learn more about our Cloud TPU
alpha programs.
I see all the cell phones.
[LAUGHTER]
As an AI researcher
myself, I can tell you
that the research
implications of TPUs
are significant, as well, which
is why I'm so excited also
about the TensorFlow
Research Cloud,
a cluster of 1,000
Cloud TPUs that we're
making available to top machine
learning researchers for free.
As an example, we shared the
news about our cloud TPUs
with Harvard Medical
School and they're
eager to use our TensorFlow
Research Cloud to do research
at the national scale.
That just hasn't been
possible until now.
We're setting up a program to
accept applications for access
to the TensorFlow
Research Cloud,
and you can sign up to
learn more about this.
I especially encourage students
and Kaggle users to apply.
These are exciting times.
Google has spent
years developing
some of the most
advanced AI in the world.
And the emergence
of the Cloud means
you can share it with everyone,
from start-ups to enterprises,
from health care to retail,
and everything in between.
We created the Cloud AI
team to make AI democratic,
to meet you where you are
with Google's most powerful AI
tools, and to share the
journey as you put them to use.
Whether you're building state of
the art machine learning models
from scratch or just
want turnkey solutions
for immediate
results, we're here
to support you at
every step of the way.
Now, to tell you
more about how Google
is improving development for
the web, please welcome Tal.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
TAL OPPENHEIMER:
Thanks, Fei Fei.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Tal from the
Chrome team, and I'm
excited to tell you about
some of the great improvements
we've made on the web
over this last year.
The web is big.
With over 2 billion
instances of Chrome,
we know that the web
has tremendous reach.
But one of the real
strengths of the web
is that it's bigger
than a single browser.
Various estimates show
that there are well
over five billion
actively-used devices,
and regardless of
whether that device is
a smartphone or a laptop
or a desktop or a tablet,
they all have a browser.
And that means
that any web app is
available on these
billions of devices today.
And we've seen this have a
real impact on how many users
web apps are reaching.
We've all seen how quickly
mobile has been growing,
and native apps
have been growing
at a tremendous pace with it.
But what's really remarkable
is that, even with the web's
large initial reach, we've
seen the average monthly web
audience growing even faster.
And because of
this growth, we're
seeing the web expand
into new areas,
with experiences
like web VR being
built on the web platform.
And the web continues to pop
up in more and more places,
even some we didn't
really expect.
A couple of weeks ago,
McDonald's announced
that they used the web and
Polymer to build their new menu
boards.
So now, when you're
looking at the menu
at McDonald's, that's
built on the web, as well.
So with the web pretty
much everywhere,
we're constantly trying
to push the boundaries
on what it can do.
If you look at all of our
launches since last year's I/O,
we've shipped 215
additional APIs
that cover a range
of capabilities
for making it easier
to integrate payments
into your experience, to
making it possible to build
fully-capable off-line
media experiences directly
on the web.
And with all of these
new capabilities,
we've seen a massive growth in
experiences built on the web.
Accelerated mobile
pages, or AMP pages,
make it really
easy for publishers
to easily create fast articles.
And since launch,
we've seen this
grow to over 2 billion AMP pages
from across 900,000 domains.
And beyond AMP pages,
the modern mobile web
also allows developers to build
deep, rich mobile experiences
with something that we call
Progressive Web Apps, or PWAs.
PWAs are about helping
web developers leverage
the web's new capabilities to
build high-class experiences
that feel immersive.
They can load quickly
and work offline,
and can even send
notifications to users.
And we've seen a number of
amazing experiences taking
advantage of these
new capabilities.
As just one example, there's
Twitter who recently rebuilt
their mobile web experience.
Here, they have a polished,
fast, immersive experience that
works on any connection type.
And it can send
users notifications,
and it's completely
built on the mobile web
so it's already accessible
on billions of devices.
And with an immersive
experience like this,
we also want to
make sure that users
can get back to it easily.
Add to Home Screen has
always allowed users
to add any experience on the web
directly to their Android home
screen, but with our improved
Add to Home Screen flow,
when you add a PWA
to your home screen,
it's fully-integrated
into the platform.
So to users, it feels like
any other app experience
on their device.
It will appear in
the Android launcher
alongside your Android
apps, and it'll even appear
in Android storage settings.
But since it's a PWA,
it's inherently smaller,
with Twitter's Progressive
Web App at under one megabyte.
So users are getting a
comparable experience
that requires significantly
less storage space.
And the fact that it's
so small doesn't just
reduce its storage
size, but also means
that it loads almost instantly
on any connection type.
And this fast, integrated,
improved Add to Home Screen
flow is rolling out now.
With all of these
new capabilities,
we've also been working
to make sure it's
really easy for web developers
to build these experiences.
We'll be going into a lot more
detail on how to develop PWAs
throughout the mobile web
track over the next few days.
But no matter how you're
building your web app,
Lighthouse is a tool
that can show you how
to improve your web experience.
Lighthouse is a Chrome
extension and command line
tool that runs almost
100 audits on your site
to identify how you can
improve your app's performance,
accessibility, and
Progressive Web App-iness.
And we're excited to
announce that Lighthouse
will be integrated
directly into Dev Tools.
So now you can quickly see
how your website is doing
and what to do next
directly in Chrome.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
And with all of
these tools, we've
seen just how easy it
can be for companies
to take advantage of these
new capabilities for their web
experience.
To give one example, there's
wego, one of the biggest travel
players in Southeast
Asia and the Middle East,
that built one of the most
polished PWAs we've seen.
Their experience works
quickly whether you're
online or offline.
They link off to AMP pages to
ensure that pages load quickly,
as well, and they leverage
some of the newest web
APIs to make payments
and identity really
easy for their users.
But what's really remarkable is
that this core PWA experience
was built in just
over two months
by a single engineer who
was new to web development.
And this is just
one example of many.
Leveraging the modern
mobile web is now
the norm around the world.
We've seen companies everywhere
building progressive web apps
and seeing a tangible
impact on their key metrics.
With the modern mobile web,
it's possible to easily build
immersive, fully-capable
experiences that
can reach billions of people
around the world today.
And now, let's turn
our focus to what
we're doing to help make
it easier to develop apps
and grow your business.
Please join me in welcoming Ben.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
BEN GALBRAITH: Thanks, Tal.
Hey, everyone.
Last year at I/O, we introduced
an expanded Firebase,
a mobile development
platform that helps you
with things like storing
data in the Cloud
and synchronizing
it across devices,
pinpointing app crashes, sending
targeted notifications to just
the right users, serving
ads in your apps, and more.
All of this is bundled together
in a single, easy-to-use,
cross-platform SDK.
Firebase also includes a
powerful, free, and unlimited
analytics tool purpose-built
for the needs of native apps.
And new this year, Analytics
gives you real-time views
into what's happening
inside of your app, which
opens up a live window into
what's happening right now.
Firebase is also integrated
with the Google Cloud
Platform, which means it scales
with you as your needs grow.
For example, Analytics
connects seamlessly
with BigQuery,
which means you can
execute fast SQL-like queries
over your data at scale.
Since last year's launch,
over a million developers
are using Firebase.
We are so humbled
that so many of you
have taken this journey
with us and have
chosen to use us in your app.
We are deeply
committed to Firebase
and we're doubling
down on our efforts
to simplify more everyday
developer challenges.
To that end, in January, the
Fabric team joined Google.
Since first launching
Crashlytics in 2011,
the Fabric team has been on
a similar mission to ours
and have built a remarkable set
of products that have achieved
widespread developer adoption.
The Firebase and
Fabric teams are
hard at work integrating
these two platforms together
in a thoughtful way to
bring you the best of both.
We'll have more to share on
this front in the coming months.
Over the past year,
we've been continuously
improving and
expanding Firebase,
and today, I want to highlight
a couple of the enhancements
that we've made, starting
with Cloud Functions.
One of our goals with
Firebase is freeing you
from having to think about
servers and infrastructure
so that you can focus
on creating great apps.
But something's been missing
for us to truly accomplish
this goal, and it's
a gap that we're now
able to fill with Cloud
Functions for Firebase, which
we just recently
released into beta.
Cloud Functions
gives you an easy way
to deploy JavaScript
code into the Cloud,
and this deployed code is
automatically mapped to a URL,
but it can also integrate
with Firebase events.
And these functions are run in
a managed, Node.js environment
so you can easily tap in to the
vast node package ecosystem.
You can use these
functions to do things
like respond to
a database update
by sending a notification
with Cloud Messaging,
or you can resize images
uploaded by your users
before saving them
with Cloud Storage.
And today, we're opening
up a new integration
between functions
and Firebase Hosting.
Now, hosting lets you
serve static content
like HTML and CSS files that
are automatically backed
by a global caching network.
By combining this
with Cloud Functions,
you can now generate
dynamic web content
that you can serve on your own
domain with the static content
and is both accelerated by
this global caching network.
So with Cloud Functions, you can
deploy individual units of code
as you need them, which gives
you a really elegant way
to factor code
out from your apps
and share them across
your web and native apps
as you need without having
to worry about app servers
or server site applications.
And it enables true
server list development.
We are really
excited about this.
All right.
I've got one more thing
I want to share with you,
and this has to do with
your native apps quality.
As developers, we
spend a lot of time
optimizing and testing our apps
to get them to perform just
right, but once we release
them into the wild,
it's really only
our users who know
how well they're performing.
That's because it's pretty hard
to know exactly how they're
behaving across a
huge array of devices
and widely-variable network
conditions across the world.
And not having our
apps perform well
is frustrating for everyone.
So today, I'm pleased
to share that we're
releasing a new product to help,
called Firebase Performance
Monitoring.
After you add
Firebase Performance--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
After you add Firebase
Performance to your app
with one line of code, Firebase
Performance automatically
provides insights into two
of the most critical aspects
of app performance--
startup time and network
responsiveness.
You can then use
its simple API--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
You can use its
simple API to measure
virtually anything in your app.
As you see on the
slide, you just
invoke a function at the
beginning and then at the end,
and Firebase Performance
does the heavy-lifting
of collecting all of the
performance metrics for you
across all of your
app instances.
And then you can
filter these metrics
by country, device type,
OS, and app version
to get a clear view of where
you need to focus your efforts.
The beta version of Firebase
Performance is available today.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
We hope this makes a big
difference in your efforts
to create high-performing
native apps.
We have a bunch of other
Firebase announcements today
at sessions here at
I/O, including support
for phone number authentication,
and we're open-sourcing
many of our Firebase SDKs.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thanks to new enhancements,
we've also made the Firebase
Test Lab for Android, and our
recently-released Unity and C++
SDKs, Firebase is great
for games developers too.
We want Firebase to be
the best place for you
to start your next app,
freeing your energies
to focus on making
your app awesome, which
is where you should be
spending all your time.
Thank you.
Now I'd like to
bring Jason back out.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON TITUS: Thanks, Ben.
As you can see,
at Google we have
been working across
a range of teams
to make it easier
to build products.
During I/O, you'll
have an opportunity
to go deep into a number of
these, with 14 content tracks
and over 140 breakout
sessions covering everything
from Android, to
the Cloud, to VR.
We also have Sandboxes to help
you get hands-on experience
with our products, as well as
over 70 code labs to get you up
and running with our
latest APIs today.
In addition, the Googlers that
built these products are here.
So grab them for one-on-one
consultations in office hours
or at the Sandboxes.
Not only can they help you
understand our products,
but more importantly,
they can get your feedback
on how we're doing.
I do have one other
announcement before we go out
to breakout sessions.
As you can tell, we're really
excited about the future of AI,
and particularly our
Google Assistant platform.
And so to get you
ramped up, we're
hosting our first-ever Actions
on Google developer challenge.
By building creative,
useful, or simply
fun apps for the
Google Assistant,
you can compete to win
one of over 20 prizes.
And for those of you
here at Shoreline,
we're giving you a Google Home
device and $700 of Cloud credit
to get you started.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
We cannot wait to
see what you build.
So Sundar talked about the
technological shift to AI,
as well as the power
of open platforms.
It's a really exciting
time in computing.
We hope you're as inspired
as we are about the future.
And remember, all
of us here at Google
are here to help you this week,
so please take advantage of it.
Let's build great
things together.
Thank you, and have fun.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]